[Musik]
nicht viele wohnungslose wollen über
ihre situation sprechen caro ist bereit
dazu sie ist 73 jahre alt
seit der rentnerin wegen eigenbedarf die
wohnung gekündigt wurde ist eine garage
ihr notdürftiges zu hause das ist
eigentlich verboten doch etwas
bezahlbares findet karol mit ihren
hunden nicht so läuft sie tagsüber durch
die stadt bis es dunkel wird aus angst
von den nachbarn entdeckt zu werden
mit beobachten dass ich rein und wieder
raus komme weil das ist verboten in der
garage zu gut denn wirklich echt ärger
kriegen wie lange die das hübsche das
ist der zweite wind werden ich habe mir
nie vorstellen können dass ich obdachlos
werde weil ich hab immer immer
gearbeitet und immer dafür gesorgt dass
und einigermaßen gut geht die chance
hier ist ganz ganz gering um eine
wohnung zum bekommt die auch
dementsprechend nur kostet was wir
bezahlen kann denn ich könnte jetzt
meine ganze rente dahin geben aber ich
habe dann ja auch nichts zu essen und zu
trinken mehr das bringt mir auch nichts
ich finde das mit recht dass man mir
auch gesagt habe ich soll erst die hunde
ins tierheim bringen und dass man denn
das für mich machen könnte könnte das
ist ja immer noch nicht sicher hat das
nennen was es gibt und
das ist für meine kinder meine babys die
gebiet doch nicht her
wohnungslose frauen fallen in der
öffentlichkeit weniger auf doch nach
schätzungen machen sie rund ein viertel
der betroffenen aus aus scham versuchen
viele ihre not zu verbergen auch caro
unterhalte mich ganz normal mit den und
die wissen nicht dass ich obdachlos bin
weil das auch zum teil auch peinlich ist
nahezu erzählen man schämt sich doch
dass man irgendwie
obdachlos ist nur
ich lass mich nicht runterziehen nur
weil oft ratlos bin dass ich nicht lache
oder was im gegenteil ich möchte ziel
noch laufen man muss lachen weil sonst
geht man kaputt
[Musik]
immer mehr menschen in deutschland sind
wohnungslos darunter auch viele
geflüchtete
schätzungen zufolge steigt die zahl der
wohnungslosen seit 2008 stetig an
inzwischen könnten es laut
bundesarbeitsgemeinschaft
wohnungslosenhilfe
fast eine million betroffene sein
wir wollen die treffen die oft
unsichtbar bleiben begleiten
wohnungslose menschen zu ihren
versteckten rückzugsorten
[Musik]
eine sozialarbeiterin der diakonie nimmt
uns mit auf einen campingplatz zu sascha
der 39 jährige hat gerade erst
feierabend
vor einem halben jahr ging sein
bisheriges leben in die brüche da verlor
er sein zuhause ich hatte 16 jahre
beziehungen tanja und dann haben wir uns
getrennt und ihr gehörte das
dann musste ich ja so gucken mich bei
obdachlosen unterkunft kann ich nicht
weil ich hab ja die katze den gebe ich
nicht ab
und dann hab ich gedacht erst mal zelten
war ja noch warm aus
welchen gründen würden sie sagen hat das
bis jetzt alle gehalten diese situation
war ich mir eigentlich erstmal arbeit
gesucht habe was wichtiger war
eine zeitarbeitsfirma gefunden wo ich
zufrieden bin
seit september arbeitet sascha dort im
schichtdienst für einen fensterbauer
damit kann er das hier finanzieren eine
bezahlbare wohnung findet er nicht
wir sind also die abende gerade wenn es
kälter wird und
man gewöhnt stadtrand das halt nichts da
es
keine wohnung dann ist warm anziehen nur
mit jogging hose und pulli schlafen
gehen also spielen wir mal hoffen dass
nicht
alles besser wie in einem pappkarton
[Musik]
oder im zelt
wie kann es sein dass sich menschen wie
sascha die sogar arbeit haben keine
wohnung mehr leisten können und warum
geschieht so wenig dagegen
darüber wollen wir mit andrej holm
sprechen der soziologe forscht seit
jahren zu stadt erneuerungen und
wohnungspolitik
im reichsten land der europäischen union
dann fast eine million menschen nicht
mit wohnung versorgt sondern müssen in
informellen arrangements oder sogar auf
der straße leben oder in staatlichen
unterkünften und das ist glaube ich ein
sozialer skandal
und dazu kommt dass jetzt das ist so was
wie eine verdeckte wohnungslosigkeit
gibt also dass die sozialen sichtbare
obdachlosigkeit von dem die unter der
brücke schlafen und am bahnhof stehen wo
zahlen nur die spitze des eisberges ist
die bekämpfung von wohnungslosigkeit ist
aufgabe der länder und kommunen
beratungsstellen notunterkünfte
tagestreffs unterschiedlichster träger
arbeiten gegen ein immer gewaltigere
problem an das angebot ist groß aber
auch unübersichtlich und regional extrem
verschieden
wir sind mit einer wissenschaftlerin
verabredet die die probleme des
deutschen hilfesystems genau kennt wir
treffen sie während einer gastprofessur
in den niederlanden luisa schneider ist
sozial anthropologin am max planck
institut in halle das stichwort
hilfesystem wie funktioniert unser
traditionelles hilfesystem im moment
befinden wir uns in einer situation wo
wir wohnungslosigkeit managen nicht
beheben durch die zahlen die wir
offiziell haben wirkt es noch so
zumindest an den in den meisten städten
in den meisten kommunen dass das geht
wenn wir uns aber jetzt wirklich
intensiver mit dem problem beschäftigen
und verstehen wie viele menschen das
betrifft dann geht das nicht mehr und
dann geht das auch nicht nur aus
sozialer perspektive nicht mehr sondern
es geht
finanziell ich es geht für das
gesundheitssystem nicht es geht für
sozialsystem ist und es geht für unsere
gesellschaft auch nicht
seit jahren forscht luisa schneider zu
den lebensbedingungen wohnungsloser
menschen sie konnte das vertrauen
hunderte betroffene in ganz deutschland
gewinnen die sich selten oder gar nicht
an kommunale einrichtungen wenden die
probleme des hilfesystems beginnen oft
mit der frage wie man überhaupt hilfe
findet man kann ja einfach bei sich
selbst anfangen und sich überlegen okay
wenn ich jetzt plötzlich meine wohnung
verlieren weiß ich dann genau so welchem
amt ich muss was ich ausfüllen muss was
ich beantragen kann überhaupt was mir
zusteht
und nein dieses wissen ist überhaupt
nicht bekannt und dazu kommt dann
natürlich auch
die
angst sich irgendwie bloßzustellen und
es gibt halt keine
koordinierte klare strategie weil
niemand
die verantwortung trägt bisher die
verantwortung liegt auf den menschen die
wohnungslosen
über die caritas haben wir in bayern
zwei geschwister kennen gelernt sie sind
wohnungslos wollen nicht erkannt werden
bis vor kurzem haben sie mit ihrem vater
in einer gemeinsamen wohnung gelebt als
die familie wegen finanzieller probleme
ausziehen musste sind die kinder
notdürftig bei freunden untergekommen
ihr vater im keller einer bekannten
hauses besonders sobald wir hier
rausgehen weil ich das jetzt das drin
und da anders geht es nicht
sonst verliert man wirklich den mut und
lust
es ist halt total unangenehm weil
niemand so leben sollte aber am grab
wann so familie ist es halt
schwierig
die geschwister sind gerade volljährig
geworden ihr vater andreas ist 55
auf zwölf quadratmetern schläft er
inmitten der umzugskartons alles was
noch geblieben ist
auf dauer ist das ganze sturm auch jetzt
ist es ganz zustand es sollte ein moment
sein
der größte wunsch der drei ist es
endlich wieder eine gemeinsame wohnung
zu finden
die drei berichten von problemen mit dem
amt als andreas nach einer firmenpleite
arbeitssuchend war hilfen seien nicht
gekommen oder erst zu spät die rücklagen
waren schnell aufgebraucht inzwischen
hat andreas wieder einen job im stahlbau
wurden
und
alles für teure mieten steigen
bezahlbaren wohnraum gibt es immer
weniger
gleichzeitig immer mehr leerstand
dringend notwendige sozialwohnungen
entstehen nicht schnell genug
nicht nur in berlin wir finden jemanden
der in einer der teuersten städte
deutschlands lebt seit sieben jahren
ohne wohnung in hamburg sind die
mietpreise in den letzten zehn jahren
explodiert volker kann sich das nicht
leisten er schläft in einer art einem
kleintransporter auf drei rädern
bevölkerungsgruppe der obdachlosen
und ich lebe auf der straße hier in
meiner kleinen aber das ist mein
himmelbett auf drei rädern
ich denke so sollte kein mensch leben in
dieser gesellschaft
die nässe und wenn's nicht warm genug
ist dass die kritiker nichts noch
zeitweise war der 66-jährige in
notschlafstellen untergebracht durch die
überfüllten unterkünfte machten ihm zu
schaffen das versteckte leben in seiner
mappe ist ihm lieber die obdachlosen die
nicht so auffallen die werden gar nicht
bekommen erst dann wenn sie darüber
berichtet tempel haben obdachlos und
dementsprechend behandelt man
volker war unternehmer hatte eine
tischlerei dann kam die insolvenz
erinnerungen an früher trägt er immer
bei sich einen zeitungsbericht über
einen schülerwettbewerb von 1966
das auch obdachlose haben
restauriert zu behalten
insbesondere auch von es zeit die man
anders war und
damit ungefähr elf jahre alt und ich
finde es erstaunlich dass ich
mein leben
geschichte den artikel immer noch habe
also
rein theoretisch müsste vom weg sein
aber das nicht nur noch habe und das
völlig weg treu
volker hört sich mit seiner lage
arrangiert auch wenn er findet dass sich
in der gesellschaft dringend etwas
ändern müsste
wenn ich den erzählungen von
einigen gleichgesinnten oder betroffenen
glauben schenke dann ist es so dass da
auch gewesene millionäre dabei wollen
die jetzt blickt jetzt gerade in der
obdachlosigkeit befinden
es wird wahrscheinlich auch in der
richtung demnächst mehr
da sein die das irgendwie kriegt
debatten kriegen
und der dann auf der straße lag
gravierendes ändern
in einer gemeinsamen verpflichtung der
eu staaten hat sich auch deutschland
verpflichtet bis 2030 sollen ganz europa
niemand mehr auf der straße leben müssen
dass wir mit klimaabkommen die man
schließt und wo man dann auch nicht kurz
danach darüber diskutieren kann ob man
es jetzt wirklich ernst gemeint hat oder
nicht also das ziel darf nicht mehr zur
diskussion stehen sondern nur der weg
dahin und da fahren wir als nächstes
jahr eine klare datengrundlage und das
muss dann auch die letzte dieser art
sein ab dann darf die kurve nur noch
abfallen
also ich glaube es müssen zwei dinge
passieren ganz grundsätzlich zum einen
müssen wir aufhören wohnungslosigkeit zu
managen und wohnungslosigkeit beheben
das geht nur wenn wir wohnungsverlust
nicht mehr als individuelles sondern ein
soziales problem sehen und dann auch die
soziale verantwortung dafür übernehmen
das würde bedeuten dass wir weggehen von
einem löse deine probleme und dann hast
du eine wohnung für die zu einem
grundsätzlichen uneingeschränkten jeder
mensch hat eine wohnung verdient und
dann lösen wir die sozialen probleme das
ist das housing first concept zuerst
eine wohnung housing first ein
amerikanisches modell das seit kurzem
auch in deutschen städten erprobt wird
statt wohnungslose immer nur temporär
unterzubringen bekommen sie eine eigene
mietwohnung die basis mit der sich alle
anderen probleme viel besser angehen
ließen wir fliegen nach helsinki denn in
finnland wurde housing first als
nationale strategie umgesetzt die zahl
der wohnungslosen wurde von 17.000 auf
rund 4000 verringert wir verabreden uns
mit einem der wichtigsten akteure der
fondation den größten non profit
wohnungsanbieter mag ihnen gilt als der
architekt der neuen finnischen
wohnpolitik
seit 2008 haben wir den umgang mit
wohnungslosigkeit in finnland komplett
geändert mit dem ziel die langfristige
wohnungslosigkeit die chronische
wohnungslosigkeit zuerst zu beenden
um das zu schaffen muss man dauerhaften
wohnraum zur verfügung stellen also
haben wir die nationale strategie
gestartet die wir housing fressen
wir hatten seitdem mehrere regierungen
und alle waren sich einig auf ein ende
der obdachlosigkeit hinzuarbeiten
für uns ist das eine frage der
menschenrechte
und housing first ist hier erfolgreich
vier von fünf personen finden so in ein
geregeltes leben zurück eine nachhaltige
investition für die finnen weil kein
umfassendes hilfesystem mehr finanziert
werden muss spart das land statistisch
15.000 euro im jahr pro wohnungsloser
person ehemalige notunterkünfte wie
diese wurden zu wohnraum
es ist keine frage des geldes es ist
immer günstiger dauerhafte lösungen
dauerhaften wohnraum zur verfügung zu
stellen als das problem nur mit
notunterkünften oder hostels zu
verwalten ich denke letztendlich ist es
vor allem eine frage des politischen
willens
in deutschland ist es schwer in ein haus
in first programm zu kommen vor allem
weil wohnungen fehlen bisher konnten
erst wenige hundert betroffene
bundesweit einen mietvertrag
unterschreiben in köln waren es bisher
fünf der sechste wurde die letzten zwei
monate von der stadt in diesem
heruntergekommenen hotel untergebracht
zwölf quadratmeter für zwei bewohner
jetzt zieht er um ein gemeinnütziger
kölner verein hat für ihn eine wohnung
gefunden
die leute von frings traf die mich da so
unterstützen dieses haus in furs projekt
weist ansonsten menschenleeren annehmen
können und nicht so ich habe vorurteile
du bist obdachlos du bist selber schuld
dass du obdachlos ist man also kein
mensch macht sich selber obdachlos also
das ist wahr ich hab echt glück gehabt
ich weiß nicht woran es liegt aber
dieses glück würde ich mir wirklich für
jeden menschen wünschen wir dürfen bei
seinem umzug in die neuen vier wände
begleiten
mit einer kiste in ein neues leben
für mich
scheinbar ton vom stein von meinen
schultern so weiß nicht vielleicht ist
es ja sowieso ein marathonläufer so ein
kilometer vor dem ziel auf einmal tut
gar nichts mehr weh und man weiß
vielleicht haben
dann freut
also dass ich habe gänsehaut und brauch
schön also mit jedem schritt
neues leben
ich konnte
[Musik]
doch vor aufregung schlüssel nicht
reicht
hier
48 quadratmeter hat ja nun für sich
allein für die stadt köln nur halb so
teuer wie die unterbringung im hotel
nimmt einfach erstmal so alle sorgen
also es nimmt auch so sehr viele
barrieren weil ja ohne ohne wohnung
christen nichts es ist wie so ein
teufelskreislauf also da weiß man gar
nicht wo man anfangen soll also bei der
adresse bei der wohnung beim wort und
da rauszukommen ist hausen fraglich das
nonplusultra
in unserer stellen sagt
[Musik]
caro aus kiel wird diesen winter noch
heimlich in der garage verbringen müssen
sie hat aussicht auf eine wohnung im
frühjahr
andreas sucht in bad tölz dringend
weiter ein richtiges zuhause seine
töchter wollen wieder mit ihm zusammen
wohnen
ist überglücklich er hat seine kölner
wohnung inzwischen eingerichtet und
arbeitet für einen kleinen verein
daniel und den verbleibenden mietern in
der berliner habersaat straße droht
weiter der wohnungsverlust eine
gerichtliche entscheidung steht noch aus
sascha aus gummersbach wird den winter
in seinem campingwagen verbringen müssen
und volker kann diesen winter in einen
not container den er sich mit jemandem
teilen wird er träumt weiter von einer
richtigen wohnung in hamburg
wenn wir die ganzen emotionen
herausnehmen dann wird es für uns als
gesellschaft sehr viel günstiger und
sehr viel gewinn bringende sein wenn wir
wohnungslosigkeit
vermeiden bevor sie auftaucht wenn es
geht und in den fällen wo wir das nicht
schaffen wenn wir sie beheben
bis 2030 soll niemand mehr ohne festes
obdach leben dazu hat sich auch
deutschland verpflichtet die politik
muss jetzt verantwortung übernehmen um
das problem der wohnungslosigkeit nicht
mehr nur zum managen sondern zu lösen
[Musik]